hey youtubers is Charlie so much to talk
about this marvel Tuesday we have
brand-new set pics of Ultron we have
some pictures of the new Iron Man suit
and there's a new interview with Chris
Evans where he talks about maybe not
playing Captain America at a certain
point very soon so I'm gonna start this
video off with a question what if in
Avengers 2 the Avengers were not the
good guys what if everyone else thought
of them as the villains I have a couple
of big reasons I think this is going to
be the case for at least the biggest
part of the story and I'll address some
of those Captain America rumors as it
applies to the Avengers roster change
because it all ties together real quick
if you're finding me for the first time
in saying WTF Marvel Tuesday I typically
just do Marvel movie videos every
Tuesday because I'm normally already
doing agents of shield stuff be sure to
subscribe to get everything and please
leave me suggestions on future Marvel
movie videos that you want to see me do
so let's have some fun and talk about
evil Avengers and I'm not talking about
Dark Avengers that was something in the
comic books after Civil War where there
were supervillains masquerading as
superheroes this isn't what I'm talking
about
I'm talking more about popular opinion
as it applies to hero worship you know
inside the Marvel Cinematic Universe so
first off let's talk about fandoms which
is always tons of fun remember way back
during that first Iron Man movie Tony
Stark came out as Iron Man during a live
press conference he never hid his
identity and became this
larger-than-life personality and then
after the Battle of New York in the
first Avengers movie they all became
celebrities you know inside that
universe so what happens whenever they
lose the public trust and everyone
starts hating them it's almost
unthinkable why in the name of Odin
would normal people hate the Avengers I
actually have a couple of theories let's
look at the plot we know that it's
loosely inspired by the comic Mighty
Avengers
which began after that Civil War event
Ultron who already existed in that
universe via Hank Pym co-op's one of
Tony Stark's Iron Man suits and for a
little while it seems like Iron Man is
the villain I'll be in a fake Iron Man
but normal people don't know that so you
can see why some of them might start
hating the Avengers the movie is gonna
be a little bit different from that
because Ultron does not exist in the
cinematic universe yet so he has to have
an origin story and since Hank Pym
created him
hank pym isn't going to be in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe until three months
after Avengers 2 airs they're just
changing the origin story in the movie
version Ultron is loosely going to be
based on a military version of Jarvis
that just spins out of control Captain
America the Winter Soldier kind of sets
the stage for how this is possible how
the military would come into possession
of something so dangerous you know like
a rogue AI but because it's essentially
stark Tech the Avengers get blamed by
the public that is and you get your evil
Avengers the big problem is is that
there's so much that has to happen in
this movie to one resolve the Ultron
situation set up the infinity gems and
push things into Phase three what has to
happen in order to accomplish all those
goals well you have to kill an Avenger
to catalyze public trust back in their
favor
not just any Avenger a big Avenger
Captain America crazy I know but it's
been done before for different reasons
remember Captain America died at the
conclusion of civil war before being
resurrected later so even if Joss Whedon
does kill him he'll be back remember
there's no such thing as permanent death
in the comic books or in the comic book
movies why do I think it's going to be
Captain America though mostly just
because during a recent interview Chris
Evans says that he thinks he'll be done
with the character by 2017 which is just
enough time to squeeze out a third
Captain America film there have also
been rumors that the Winter Soldier
might potentially replace him which was
also a part of the comic books during
that Civil War story if you're not
familiar I'm talking about the character
the Winter Soldier taking up the costume
in the shield of Captain America not
Sebastian Stan but Sebastian Stan would
be playing the Winter Soldier playing
Captain America so it's a character
playing another character didn't Robert
Downey jr. totally do something like
that in Tropic Thunder I'm a dude
pretending to be another dude pretended
to be another dude that was just a great
movie the alternate theory though is
that it's Hawkeye who's killed
Coulson style you know just to bring
everyone together meeting Captain
America's death could always be
postponed til that third Captain America
film either way the Avengers will be
very unpopular until something catalyzes
public opinion you know post Ultron and
we really do have to upgrade
seven statuses Captain America to DEFCON
3 as in might be gone soon if you
consider 2017 to be soon in my opinion
though major roster changes in the
Avengers as well as changes and actors
won't really happen till after of
industry maybe not even till in phase
four even the most expensive person
Robert Downey jr. has a contract that
extends through Avengers 3 which isn't
scheduled until 2019 so now it's your
turn let me know do you think that
everyone is going to blame the Avengers
for the creation of Ultron and all the
destruction he causes and what do you
think has to happen in order to fix that
obviously in my opinion I think it has
to be a dead Avenger you know who that
Avenger is is still up for debate so in
other big news Captain America the
Winter Soldier is finally hitting
theaters next Thursday not this Thursday
but next week I'll be doing a movie
reviews of that be sure to subscribe to
get it
my next Marvel Tuesday video will
probably be my top choices for new
Avengers because remember we're going to
be cycling in new members pretty soon
right now click here to learn more about
Avengers 2 and click here to learn about
my top picks for the stories for Captain
America 3 thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high fives